all right
okay welcome to the ddk seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over uh some rules and
Logistics first of all please meet
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions you are
welcome to admit and ask otherwise
please use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q a session at the end second today's
gdps seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host uh Jan dugona who is a
senior data scientist and the principal
investigator in the physics and
computational science division at pnnl
Jan has a PHD in control engineering
from the Slovak University of Technology
in blood blood test blood Slover
Slovakia and before joining pnnl he was
a postdoc at the mechanical engineering
department at KU leuven in Belgium his
current research is focused on
differential differentiable programming
for scientific machine learning
constraint optimization and model based
optimal control with applications in the
energy sector including building control
and Power Systems optimization today Jan
will talk about differentiable
differential
programming for modeling and control of
dynamical systems which is very
interesting topics so please enjoy now
without further Ado let me pass the
button to Yan by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question is what is the most beautiful
place you have ever seen
that's very very difficult to answer but
I will be a little bit territorial right
now in Washington State and I really
fall in love with Washington State
because of the mountains such as Mount
Rainier and untouched nature glaciers
Cascades everyone who should visit and
if you are in the area we can go on a
hike awesome okay so I guess you love
hiking oh very much so nature is the
best place to stay I totally agree all
right okay stays is yours yeah
thank you very much for this wonderful
um introduction and also unexpected
random question and uh for for having me
it's a really great honor to be invited
to as a speaker to this uh seminar which
I was following uh throughout the year
with great content and today I want to
present the perspective of the broader
team at p l which is consisting of
people from Deep learning background
power system background Aerospace
electrical engineering control
engineering that is working together on
developing differential programming
methods for modeling and control of
dynamic systems with the first challenge
being system modeling simulations are
crucial for many areas of decision
making and scientific discovery and
National Labs in general are
primed to develop large-scale High
Fidelity simulation models and data
driven models for complex Engineering
Systems such as power system networks
building energy systems or
or unmanned vehicles for underwater
measurements and there is a need to
improve the computational efficiency and
scalability of heterogeneous scientific
simulations classically you are solving
physics-based models with numerical
methods but recently there is a new
trend of
bringing more machine learning in place
and replacing interactive solvers with
neural networks and a lot of new
exciting areas of research of hybrid
architectures with physics informed and
neural networks or machine learning in
our team we are on on the track of
objectives of developing domain agnostic
software tools and algorithmic
Frameworks that could combine these
scientific Computing methods with data
science models and be supported by high
performance Computing available at
National Labs there are a lot of
applications in optimization modeling of
dynamic systems
uh such as optimal control
in general there are like two branches
of control model base and model 3.
a flagship of model based control is
called Model predict control and there
is a this statement from the Richard
Murray from Caltech textbook on optimal
control that says 95 of industrial
control applications rpid
control loops or proportional integral
derivative controllers there are just
three parameters very simple single
input single output controllers the rest
is model predicted control
why why such a success of model-based
approaches in Industry such as process
control Automotive Aerospace or high
performance robotics because the safety
is number one performance in terms of
the economical performance or or time is
number two
and typically these systems can be
approximated by relatively lower order
dynamical system models like
differential equations or state-based
models and you can have
a reliable prior knowledge to build
these physics-based models and you have
typically budget to employ Army of phds
to write down your differential
equations cost and optimization problems
or solve these problems uh with modern
numerical methods
on the other hand when you don't know
the underlying physics or it's too
expensive to obtain like for large power
system networks we need to do something
else
the reinforcement learning has been very
successful in domains where you have
reliable digital environment model like
computer games or board games or some
complex simulation models that don't
necessarily need to be differentiable or
have specific properties that are
required for computing Solutions like in
model base approaches
and you typically have massive compute
to solve the problem by basically
perturbing the emulator system with
trial and error observing the response
and learning the approximate Behavior to
value functions and then obtain the
control policies however the challenges
of reinforcement learning are typically
scalability you need to have a lot of
data and it's sometimes or very often
hard to satisfy performance guarantees
and safety guarantees like you have in
model-based approaches so what we see in
both communities is the trend to go in
the middle to create new hybrid methods
that leverage performance guarantees of
model based approaches and flexibility
of reinforcement learning in in a
coherent Frameworks and that's what we
are interested in doing as well at p l
in our team
but before I provide the perspective on
how we are doing that I want to take a
step back and review the landscape of
optimization methods that are Behind
These approaches in model practice
control
we are typically dealing with online
optimization solvers
we reformulate the optimal control
problem in standard
constraint optimization problem with
nonlinear objective inequality equality
constraints and we are searching for
optimal decision variables in this case
it's X that represent our control
actions
with every new measurement of our
initial conditions or boundary
conditions or changing of the task we
need to recompute the problem
and this happens on the fly in real time
so when you have reliable System model
when you have sufficient compute you can
do that very efficiently very robustly
with
very good performance guarantees but
when you don't have these models or
where you have computational limitations
it's typical very tricky and you need to
do a lot of scale down
um to alleviate this problem of the
computational
requirements in real time when you have
let's say systems microchips with
limited memory or communication
bandwidths people try to explore what is
called parametric programming where
instead of solving the optimization
problem in real time with optimization
solvers like interior point or active
sets you are trying to analytically
construct explicit solution map
that solves the problem parametrically
the unfortunate side of this is that
classical methods that deal with active
set exploration
of all possible combinations in your
car's conductor conditions
just data on scale
um they are fairly theoretical at this
stage
and here where machine learning comes
people in these domains have been using
imitation learning for quite some time
to approximate these parametric
Solutions with regression methods or
classification methods on the label data
sets of the control parameters like
initial boundary conditions and map to
the label data set of optimal decisions
that are obtained by solving a
distribution of the optimization
problems with iterative solvers or by
obtaining expert
um as expert Solutions let's say by
human drivers this is scalable
but it requires relatively large amount
of data to cover all the parametric
space and it's very hard to obtain
performance guarantees because you are
just dealing with simple regression
problems
um
then you still are requiring the expert
to deliver your solution that can be
expensive to have human expert or have
optimization problem at the first place
when you don't have the model so
reinforcement learning is probably the
most flexible approach where you have
very little assumptions the only thing
you need to have is the system you can
per troop and observe the responses and
the rewards to learn your critic and
actor
getting deep reinforcement learning both
of them are deep neural networks and the
critic is just mapping over State action
pairs into reward signals scalar valued
function of the fitness of your model
now you can differentiate it to obtain
the policy gradients that's the whole
trick that you are using automatic
differentiation here so the question is
how can we alleviate the obstacles of
reinforcement learning for safety
critical systems by bringing more domain
knowledge and how can we
improve the scalability and flexibility
of classical
optimization-based approaches by
leveraging the ideas behind
reinforcement learning which is
automatic differentiation
and here we believe and what we see the
evidence in the community is the
differentiable programming is a emerging
unifying approach for data-driven
parametric optimization which Solutions
are based on automatic differentiation
of complex functionals not only simple
machine learning functions like
meansquare on or some tracking objective
and I will quickly skim through
influential papers in a differential
programming landscape for scientific
machine learning this is no way
extensive uh list so I apologize uh for
not having every single topic listed
here
I would probably start as a very good
read a differential programming system
to bridge machine learning and
scientific Computing that is uh in 2019
paper by the Julia crowd and I think
they have been one of the first to nail
the term of differentiable programming
for cyano
and we all know famous paper on physics
and for neural networks for solving PDS
neural differential equations and the
extensions Universal differential
equations are taking good various
Dynamic systems domains by storm
and maybe not as well known but very
active area of research it's
differentiable optimization where
instead of having
ah
just neural network layers or
some functional Transformations you are
having optimization problems as
differentiable layer within the network
or you're using neural networks to
obtain the solution for optimization
problem and then you are using methods
like projections to get you to the
feasible region of your equality
inequality constraints a lot of uh work
being done very recently in this space
very very exciting and now similar ideas
can be used for control because
model pretty control especially can be
reformulated as a constraint
optimization problem where you need to
satisfy your dynamical constraints that
can be represented by your neural
differential or differential equations
and your feasible region can be
represented by some polytopic
constraints
so we see a lot of similarities
in these domains and we are building on
top of uh these Giants
and I will now present this perspective
how do we think mathematically about
these problems in our team because we
have like people from different domains
how do we bring them together to speak
the same language
so we believe that this parametric
optimization is a good
framework and
can represent kind of generalization of
physics in from neural networks I will
explain how so we start with some
objective function that is General
nonlinear differentiable function
that
is function of your Primal optimizers X
that can be like your control decisions
or
um can be parameters of your
differential equations you want to learn
from data and you have some scenarios
PSI
that represents your parametric
dependency in physics informed neural
networks these are the collocation
points yeah you would sample your domain
space in order to obtain
the inputs you are going to propagate
through neural network that needs to
satisfy the pde equation residuals but
in this case we are having General
inequality equality constraints
that needs to be satisfied and we have
the solution map that may or may not be
neural network that is mapping the
parameters to the primal optimizers
that is parameterized by the Theta this
is which is actually the
variable you want to optimize in this
overall parametric problem
so if you would deal this in a classical
sense you would need to pick one
instance of the parameter fix the
problem and uh called iterative solver
this can be very costly when you have
thousands of parameters and you want to
solve this parametrically over the whole
domain
another way is to do it it's like in
similar inspired by seasoning for neural
networks you reformulate the problem in
a lagrangian form
where you put your equalities
inequalities as penalties weighted
penalties in Europe lagrangian
objective function that now boils down
to scalar value function that is taking
basically expect
expected value over the samples of your
collocation points or pair parameters
and now we have differentiable scalar
value function that is amiable for
gradient-based optimization with
automatic differentiation so you can
back propagate the sensitivities of this
objective function
with constraint penalties to obtain the
gradients of
this differential function be the Deep
neural network that will approximate the
solution of this constraint optimization
problem
by the way if you have any questions
feel free to stop me and ask for
clarification notation or anything that
might come to mind
okay so how do we solve these problems
uh there are different approaches in the
literature in our team we found out
there are no robust toolboxes so we need
to code everything ourselves but other
teams are starting to emerge who are
working on similar uh similar directions
so this very exciting time to be
in this research area
what do we do here we call differential
parametric programming because we saw
parametric programming problems with
automatic differentiation and we are
developing python-based toolbox it's
basically a set of classes and
and functions on the top of Python's
functionality which we call Neuromancer
that's why the background
which we
which which stands for neural modules
with adaptive nonlinear constraints and
efficient regularizations
essentially it allows us to
formulate these type of problems where
you have constraints nonlinear
objectives and when you want to train
neural network to satisfy these
objectives and constraints given some
data sets
inspiration has been taken from
constraint optimization Frameworks like
CVX Pi pioma in python or jump in Julia
yeah maybe Matlab that all are based on
symbolic abstractions like you have
variable class that's the basic
primitive in these Frameworks and you
can now symbolically construct
computational graph on these variables
what we are doing here that we are
combining this with machine learning
components like deep neural network here
we have multi-layer perceptron that Maps
variable P into X and Y
and we can combine them all together
and still work relatively comfortably in
a high level API writing down your
polynomial Expressions uh
instantiating the objective functions
and defining constraints without writing
actual classes in Python so that's what
we are developing now like automatically
parse these high level Expressions into
pytouch modules with differentiable
overpasses that can be used
um in this lagrangian approaches so you
aggregate things in objective
constraints and components and in couple
of lines of code you are able to
formulate constraint optimization
problem
and now depending on the type of solver
the three most straightforward ways to
do with penalty functions but you can do
more advanced solvers like augmented
lagrangian or like you can add
projection layers that are
differentiable within the architecture I
will go through some of those in the
following slides but the idea is that
you have now
constraint optimization problem that is
implemented in pytorch that's
differentiable forward powers and you
can use stochastic gradient descent
because you have scalar value objective
function you can differentiate with auto
grad
we have been working on this for
um about two years from from now and
from the computational graph perspective
from for computer science people you can
see this mathematical formulation
as a following
a flow of information you have some data
sets these are the parameters or
collocation points RPD and this is your
neural network and here are the
objectives and constraints that needs to
be satisfied like similar in PD you want
to satisfy the residuals uh of those
equations and you aggregate everything
in the scalar value loss function beats
penalty or augmented lagrangian but we
are not solving pdes now we are solving
constraint and optimization or optimal
control problems that's the idea
um these are just two examples of two
two dimensional domains when you have
non-linear objective like given in this
Contours these are the canonical test
functions like Rosenberg and email blog
problem in constraint optimization and
we have known convex
uh feasible domain given by these blue
constraints like we have this donut
shape and the linear constant that we
want to find the solution in these
subspaces
what we found out that we can get orders
of magnitude faster online solution
compared to iterative solvers like
interior point because for each new
variation in your problem when you shift
your constraints or you tweak your
objective function you would need to
recompute the problem but when you
pre-compute the problem with
differentiable programming and learn
explicit solution it will parametrically
remember those
solutions that has been trained offline
and just spawn you an answer by single
four parts of neural net
we are getting somewhat close to Optimal
Solutions of these iterative solvers in
this green this is interior point and
red is this differentiable programming
approach it's still approximation it's
not like hard constraint guarantees or
hard uh satisfaction of the
uh optimality Gap but we found it still
like very intriguing to follow up
because we can get a lot of orders of
money to speed up and even if you have
sub-optimal solution for some
application this can be Game Changer
whether we can actually use it or not
uh in the following I want to focus on
actual architecture of this
computational graph these don't
necessarily need to be fully connected
neural networks can be any
differentiable function
for dynamic systems in particular people
have been using neural State space
models they can come in different shapes
and
and forms
In classical control theory people love
to use linear State space models and
there are different variations when you
add non-linearities in different parts
like this input Dynamics this is State
Dynamics and this is your observable
function
uh recently equipment operators are very
popular
here we are just listing different
architectures you can embed as a
computational graph and when you
replace the neural network here with
neural ordinary differential equations
then
with iterative solver then you have
neural OD
you can go even deeper in the domain
knowledge not only through architecture
of these recurrences you can also domain
you can embed domain knowledge into a
black box components let's say you have
neural network
but you know something about your system
especially about its eigenvalues about
the sparsity of the topology of the
network you can use bunch of linear
algebra priors that can help you to
bound
the singular values of the overall
non-linear transformation here we are
showing just two examples of what what
we call here spectral map and param from
a news map where on the left hand side
you instead of training
weights of neural network Black Box way
you are factorizing them in the singular
value fashion we are not solving SVD
because that will be very expensive but
we are clamping the singular values in
the certain
in certain bounds and we are
either designing left and right matrices
to be orthogonal or we are penalizing
them as a regularization so you can see
again you have additional constraints
for certain properties of your layer and
you are putting them either
as additional to run in in your scalar
value loss function
like you want to minimize the residual
like you're doing pins or you find some
tricks that would allow you to do it
let's say for free by doing uh in this
inductive priors
we implemented uh
a bunch of these inductive priors in
this open source GitHub repository which
we call Slim structured linear Maps it's
just nothing else just
checking linear algebra writing the
forward passes of of those in in
pythagen using them instead of Weights
as a drop in replacement so for any
practitioner in pytharch feel free to
uh test them out by by yourself and I
would be happy to receive any feedback
or like potential suggestions for
expansion
so that's more from methodological and
like theoretical perspective what about
practical problems
um where we can use these domain priors
one of them is modeling thermodynamics
of building Energy Systems which you can
represent as a multi-dimensional dynamic
system
under the hood is a partial differential
equation that typically in domain
Sciences is discretized into different
collocation points and you have set of
ordinary differential equations that you
can linearize and solve with with
iterative solvers
Um this can be very labor intensive it
takes months very often to design this
type of physics-based models
for single building of single system
that's not rentable that's not uh
scalable for large scale applications
and for
for any like uh monetary return of
investment
but we can use machine learning and
domain knowledge and combining together
to learn these Dynamic systems from
small amount of data if we
if you do it right
for instance we can decompose the
problem into different uh
different dynamical modules like you
have this abstract high level
computation graph of your building model
structure
where building envelope represents your
walls and ceilings basically the heat
transfer to the structure
and uh
we know something about it we know it's
dissipative what does it mean that it
wants to get to the terminal equilibrium
with the environment so it's dynamically
stable then we can construct the
recurrent neural net that resembles this
computational graph and has this
property which means that the singular
values of this operator are bounded
within the unit circle so it's
contractive
uh we can also know we also know that
this heating ventilation air
conditioning systems we did represent
the inputs to the
building envelope delivering the heat
are also bounded in certain physical
space and we can use like Metals through
clamping or projections into certain
State space of of that operator so
everything now is combined together it's
no longer Universal approximator it has
a lot of domain priors where the
partnership State space that it can can
capture is limited but is limited uh in
a good way you are going to learn only
if those parameters which you don't know
like uh what is the specific heat
transfer between the the nodes
how does it work on some real data here
is a very messy time series data set
with 20
measurements which represents zones of
the building temperatures in each of the
rooms and we have 30 days which is not
much it is one amount of data and we
split these in three
in three components like we first have
data set for training 10 days second 10
days we have for validation which is
selecting the best model and the last 10
days for testing the performance and
this is the
trajectory of the linear model where the
red is the ground rule trajectory and
the blue
is the prediction of the model
linear models can be very good local
approximators you can obtain the model
that is valid for a certain period of
time but as the you shift your
distribution of the disturbances
operating conditions
it can blow away it can diverge from its
own predictions and you would need to
retrain your model with new data again
on the other hand when you use this
neural network with Domino our priors
you can get way more robust prediction
because now you have your state space
constraints
in a way you are expecting the the
behaviors of your model and you can
train this to be generalizable
for a longer period of time
so this has been done on like real world
data with buildings
with the purpose of having reliable
System Dynamics model they don't require
a lot of data but they still leverage
some domain Knowledge from the building
physics engineers
okay so that's the first step we can do
forecast
what can we do with these models Beyond
forecast is control but how do we do
control with
these complex computational graphs that
are no longer fitting the Frameworks of
classical controller you need to have
either State space model or differential
equation now we have more complicated
nonlinear transformations in place that
are
just not supported with the numerical
solvers
from the classical domain
on this landscape we have been working
on what we call differential operating
control
where the idea is nothing else again
leverage automatic differentiation in
the same way as we are doing system
identification of dynamic systems or
solving constant optimization problems
in lagrangian forms so kind of the pins
idea where you have
distribution of your collocation points
or control parameters these are the
features that you propagate through the
computation graph that is consisting of
the control policy and System Dynamics
model this is a closed loop system and
now you see the resemblance with
reinforcement learning for those people
who are working in this dead space you
have actor and you have your system
model but the system model is not
outside
of your differentiable computation graph
it's a part of it now we can
differentiate through the model because
you have learned this differentiable
transformations
this allows you to build model-based
value functions you don't need to have
black box neural network to represent
your value function now you can embed
prior knowledge
by doing reference tracking parametric
equations or doing penalties and
constraints and you don't need to
approximate that part
so we have been working on this for last
two years
and I will show you example of this
hello world in control theory of
stabilize unstable double integrator
with this parametric objective function
or
tracking the references for State space
and
minimizing the energy used while
satisfying the boundary conditions for
your control actions
mathematically you can formula formulate
this as a parametric optimal control
problem
where you are minimizing the scalar
value loss function over the
expectations of the sampled parametric
scenarios or qualification points in
your
in your parametric space
over the performance objective penalties
on
the state and control actions
subject to
this recurrent
equality constraints that represents
your dynamic system in this case it's
simple linear system but it could be
differential equation it could be neural
differential equation anything that can
approximate the behavior of a dynamic
system
and we have this neural network that is
mapping the state space and the
parametric space like
changing inequality constraints into
control actions
and you can formulate this as a these
nice computational graph that propagates
the collocation points through the
control policy System Dynamics model and
you impose constraints on control
actions the response of the Dynamics
model that is unrolled over several
steps ahead into the future in the model
pretty control fashion and then you have
this scalar valid loss function that
Aggregates all together and because
every single component is differentiable
now you can compute the sensitivities
with calling backward
pass and applying simple chain Rule and
this will allow you to propagate the
sensitivities back to the control policy
to obtain direct policy gradients it's a
very same idea that you would use in
reinforcement learning where you have
your actor that's the policy
and then you have your value function
that's that's your critic but the critic
is like basically approximating all of
these components this is just taking
step back from the engineering
perspective
let's decompose the critic into System
Dynamics control objective control
constraints and put them all together in
weighted objective functions
how does it work in training we found
out if the problem is well posed it can
train very fast in under 100 epochs we
can stabilize this system you can see
the trajectories on the left hand side
and policy landscape on the right hand
side and it can train very fast without
too much of the compute and
a maximum amount of data because you
don't need to approximate the reward
function or the value function it's
already embedded through physics
knowledge
okay what happens when we don't have
perfect physics knowledge of the system
Dynamic model or we need to train it
from
from uncertain data we have been working
on extension to stochastic
dynamical systems again this is a Hello
World example with linear systems spread
to buy some distributions
um
technically the idea is very simple you
are just adding orthogonally one more
Dimension to sample
and these are the answer to empty so
alongside the parameters your sampling
also uncertainties and you're training
the control policies to to control the
system like in this case stabilize
to the reference or do the obstacle
avoidance we turn non-linear constraints
subject to changing parameters like
positions or shape of the obstacle and
varying signals of your perturbations
that are sampled from some assumed
distributions
this works
surprisingly well without
much change of the code there are a
couple of lines you add
um but you pay the cost of having more
collocation points and it becomes a
little bit more expensive offline so it
is open research like what is the right
way of sampling
your parametric space where do you need
to sample like maybe on the decision
boundaries of your constraints you would
need to have more denser sampling and
indeed in the interior of your physical
region you need less dense sampling and
there are similar ideas in pieces
informed neural networks that use like
let's say optimal transfer for answering
the question so I leave it here as an
open question
um
second
important topic we are working on is how
do we provide some kind of robustness
and stability guarantees for this type
of learning based controllers because
everything is approximate you always get
to the solution with some numerical
threshold there will be always some
residuals but sometimes in real world
applications the residuals can be
difference between failing and
succeeding but the failure can have high
implication you can break the system and
it would be very costly or even like
endangering human life so
from this perspective
there are some ideas in the literature
leveraging lapino functions
differentiable functions laptop is
nothing else there's some kind of energy
function that is a positive definite has
trivial no space and basically is if you
follow the trajectories alongside this
landscape you will always converge you
to the fixed Point equilibrium this is
the phase space of two-dimensional
uh dynamic system governing by the apno
function over this close-up Dynamics
so what we have been doing that we can
learn these lapino functions even if we
don't know them beforehand there are
some papers that show how to design
these lapino functions
with hard guarantees on these properties
and uh
certify closely Dynamic systems to be
converging to fixed points
so we plug them in in the closed
Dynamics and train them offline
alongside with control policies and then
in the real time we can use them as
certain certificates that in certain
State space we are converging we can
even use them as in projections to
correct our control actions if they will
be diverging from from that certified
State space
for more details uh please you can see
our papers
and I will skip to the second topic
which is exactly in the same area of
safety
that is dealing with control barrier
functions
the optional functions are
basically positive definitely they want
to push your energy towards the origin
while the control barrier functions
you can think of them as another form of
energy functions that are informing you
whether you are inside your feasible
region of your constraints and if you
are approaching to the constraint
boundary you can trigger some Behavior
like a trigger corrective control to
keep you inside
again I will skip the technical details
but the ideas are very simple very
simple implementation in terms of
similarity with latino functions you
just formulate your control barrier
function either based on prior knowledge
of your system or there are some papers
that learn control value functions from
data
and these barrier functions will give
you indicator of the constant
satisfaction that can be penalized
during training so you are like
enforcing your control system to satisfy
constraints offline and then upon
deployment they can also learn as
indicators for doing switching behavior
when you are approaching the safety
boundary you are going to switch to some
backup controller to push you back to
the feasible region again details are in
those papers both of them have been
accepted for conference and decision
control there are our recent works on
safety
more from control theoretic perspective
and how do we develop these methods from
implementation perspective but once we
have the landscape of tools
our primary objective as a National Lab
is to implement them in real world
Engineering Systems
such as building energy efficient
control
here we have simulation model of
residential building that we assume
that we have only time series data and
some prior knowledge so we measure the
temperatures the behavior of the control
system and we learn the surrogate model
the digital twin with this physics
constraint
direct rent
model that we can then plug in in a
closed loop dynamic system that
represents polarametric optimal control
and because we Implement everything as a
differentiable component we can obtain
the scalar valued functions that are
fully model based and provide us with
policy gradients of neural network that
can satisfy State constraints action
constraints for these higher dimensional
state
space
with style wiring constraints so you can
think of it as a
as a control task with wiring control
objectives yeah the parametric objective
um
so example of application
would be done like a year ago was this
multi-zone building control and
the generality of the approach allows us
to just change the system and use the
same code base
to tackle let's say economic dispatch
problem
where instead of the building now we
have power system Network
this is for example again nine bus
system with generators and and consumers
where you measure the voltages and your
frequencies as a Time series data in
this case we approximate the model with
coupon operator with some domain priors
when we know the
steady stage and we can regularize them
to those
correct study States again domain ever
surrogate model that can be plugged in a
closer dynamic system and now we can
simulate the closer dynamic system on
our collocation points
obtain
the control objectives and compute the
sensitivity of the objective with
respect to neural network control policy
and obtain explicit solution of this
parametric optimal control problem that
you would have to otherwise saw with
iterative solver like interior point
this can be very expensive especially
when you are dealing with larger scale
systems
that can take minutes up to hours to
compute their solution
this means that you cannot use your
real-time control
in practice you can only use it for
analytics afterwards and that's the the
current bottleneck of classical control
approaches but when we pre-compute the
solution offline with these
differentiable approaches we can obtain
five orders of magnet to speed up in
real time because we don't need to solve
differential algebraic equation solver
and interior Point solver in real time
like in we do a model based approaches
so this particular case gave us five
original magnitude speed up which is the
difference between using the approach as
only analytical
or actually deploying it and using it in
real time controlling the the power
Network and we also found that the
solution quality was not lost too much
like these are like from
um generate uh the voltage generators
from
interior point the solid lines and
dashed lines are from the differential
programming approach so of course you
are not nailing optimal solution but you
are getting sub-optimal solution that is
very close and satisfactory in terms of
constant satisfaction and and most
importantly the actually within your uh
communication boundaries and and
sampling rate that you can use as a
real-time control
the last slide on applications I'm
showing very true example that can serve
as a proof of concept for software or
control as a service
this work was done in collaboration with
our colleagues from University of Slovak
University of Technology in Bratislava
and they had this very toy laboratory
device when they have both floating in
the tube
that is controlled by Raspberry Pi
controller
what they did they measured the time
series of data of per tube system and we
did system identification on our hand
and used the system ID model
in differentiable control setting
training the constraint policy offline
and ship them the control policy to
deploy on this real device and they need
to compare this against classical
methods like model pretty control but
because of the computational limitations
of the microcontroller they need to
satisfy the memory bandwidth and CPU
bandwidth so they cannot use full NPC
they need to reduce the performance so
we found that pre-computing solution
offline
can beat online solution of iterative
solvers if you have limited bandwidth
in terms of reference tracking
constraint satisfaction here we are able
to deal with timering constraints
time varying references that are in
Conflict often and with heavy
um
heavy noise of the measurement variable
that was not able to be solved with
classical model predict control because
of the large computational demands but
when you pre-compute it with
differential programming and then you
have just neural network that you can
deploy and you don't need to solve the
optimization problem in real time this
can be again a game changer for
deploying Advanced controls in devices
that don't have the compute power at the
first hand
okay so that was a blitz through
different
methods and applications which you are
working on
at PLL but the underlying
methods which you binding everything
together is differentiable programming
for
constraint optimization
and optimal control methods where we are
dealing with
dynamical systems can can be
approximated by neural of these neural
status models and now they can be
embedded in constraint optimization
problems
that satisfy certain properties of
convergence to fixed points or boundary
conditions and we have means to
transforming those problems into scalar
valued objective actions that can be
differentiated with modern automatic
differentiation from Frameworks like
pythons or you could Implement these
methods in Julia or or Jax in Python
that are in Swift
our ongoing work is to focus more on
optimization solvers constraint
optimization solvers in these
differential programming setting we are
working on embedding graph neural
networks in the framework because it's
very suitable for Network Dynamic
systems like power system networks or
building thermal Networks
having some robots uncertainty
quantification that would allow you to
do smart sampling of your collocation
space and other uh interesting topic
and as a community we see a lot of
different uh
research groups working on
using differential programming for
things like calls or Discovery
discovering your uh
underlying equations of the dynamic
system discovering coupling between
Network Dynamic systems
Computing sensitivity of complex
differentiable graphs doing stability
analysis for machine learning models
that will allow you to
using conjunction with classical
physics-based principles to solve
large-scale parametric constraint
optimization and optimal control
problems that haven't been
feasible with just classical methods
before so we see this as a very exciting
time to do researching a lot of research
being done in other domains and other
groups and we are looking forward for
collaboration so if you are interested
in what we are doing at piano please see
our GitHub pages
and here I would like to thank you
everyone for your attention and thanks
to Department of energy for sponsoring
our work
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk Jan uh very interesting
talk okay uh great yeah of course
uh let's have a uh the Q a sessions
um if you have any questions please
unmute yourself and
um and ask questions let me start with a
with a question
if you go to slide 11
.
you mentioned that
you know
if yeah yeah differentiable Prime
parametric
oh was it
yeah exactly so differentiable
parametric programming um you compare
the performance with the IPO iterative
server you get the orders of magnitude
faster online Solutions so I I was not
clear about
okay so in IPL you could solve this
exact formulations you know
you know the written in in the left hand
side and you do compare the um
um the performance that way
yes so what we are doing here is that uh
we have distribution of problems that
you can think of this parametric PSI
uh as right hand side in your
you know let's say you have equality
constraint a x equals B and this PSI can
be the B Vector that is changing so
you're actually changing your
optimization problem
if you are about to solve this interior
Point method for each nuc PSI you need
to resolve the problem again that's the
specific problem you're solving
but because we want to solve this
parametrically for like the family of
the problems with neural networks
we use this lagrant generate formulation
and this pin-based idea
that will allow you to learn neural
network that Maps these parameters that
in in physics and for neural Nets would
be uh your domain your X into your
into your decision variable or solution
of the pde in in pins and that's that's
the difference between offline and
online solution of course we are paying
a lot of offline
cost for that
I mean it's so so it's a
optimization context there is a nasty
approach and you know
all at once approach it seems like
you're formulating in your framework
your output taking the elastic approach
where you embedded the you know those
right hand side for example in linear
system uh onto the
um
onto onto the domain
on constraint system
and in offline do you solve that and
then feed that into your differentiable
um the programming framework uh while
but but my in my head I think that you
can also formulate that with IPO and you
can you don't have to resolve the
optimization as every time the you know
those
what it was C value or the right hand
side value is changing
um by for example treating them as a on
other optimization variable in IPO
and as those changes
simultaneously changing those C
um and the optimization variable within
IPO so I
I don't know it sounds like it's a
matter of formulations it definitely
carry formulate the problems in
different ways but in this case we treat
this side as a parameters not as a
decision variables yeah yeah so that
could be like initial condition
or boundary condition
solving your OD type problem or optimal
control problem
uh typically you cannot treat the dose
as a decision variables because they are
given by the measurements or or some
requirements on
operational range
right I totally understood what you're
saying but in TD constraint optimization
there is a different way of treating
those the uh the parameter parameter
variables within the optimization
framework so I see so maybe I'm not
familiar about that and I would love to
hear this baby yeah leverage some of
those methods in in this approach I
would I would love to hear that all
right sounds good thank you
no no no problem okay so is there any
other questions from audiences
don't be shy
all right
um I found it slide 13th
um you know the
the concept of you know introduction of
the concept the inductive prior
um very
uh interesting like constraining the
singular values while you're doing the
training
um I'm very interested in that so I
guess this is available as an open
source code yes it's available as open
source and in many of those uh priors we
are just re-implementing published work
by other groups so we are providing the
references with those papers some of
them we develop ourselves
um just shopping to our old to good
linear algebra for inspiration yeah
exactly well I mean it's you know the
neural net you know known to be a black
box because we don't have a direct
access to those the singular values and
eigenvalue this information but looks
like you're exploiting
those areas and then take advantage of
it
um so not so much Black Box anymore if
you exactly that's
kind of philosophically in our team
rather than finding uh wondering that
rules them all one method that can solve
any abstract problem we are approaching
this on for instance per problem basis
what do we know as an Engineers as a
as Aerospace or electrical engineer or
mechanical engineer about the system
that could inform our architecture that
could inform the formulation of our
objective functions with regularization
so we
we don't learn a universal functional
approximator that can go anywhere we
just we can heavily
constrain the parametric space and the
output space of these functions that we
are learning so it fits the domain right
right right
um but but this framework only works for
the linear uh models I'm guessing well
those Transformations technically are
non-linear Transformations but they will
act as a linear weight because they
generate the linear matrices that change
at each epoch
but the idea of adding inductive priors
it can go beyond linear layers so graph
neural networks is one great example
like a lot of work being done there
people use Universal differential
equations that's coming from Julia crowd
where they combine Black Box neural
networks and known differential
equations on the right hand side of the
neural ID and we found this as a very
powerful
concept as well nice
all right I'm gonna take in two more
about that
um
very interesting yeah all right okay
um so people are shy today
let's go to so I have a question yeah oh
yeah go ahead hi thanks thanks for the
talk I was wondering um uh do you think
about any way of extending this for like
discrete action spaces is there any uh
good question of
implementation wise we already have that
but we didn't have a Manpower and time
to actually do thorough empirical tests
but we would welcome any potential
collaboration interests in like pushing
forward more more applications and
expanding uh the framework method wise
so discrete reduction space is in our
interests but it's also on kind of uh
midterm agenda I used to deal with
hybrid Dynamic systems when you have uh
State space under switching conditions
there are some early papers that deal
with neural hybrid differentiable hybrid
automata where you have finite State
machine
that has discrete switches but in each
of the state machine states you have
differential equation
that's very powerful concept and many
Engineering Systems operate under these
switching rules right right this Bing
Bond or Bam Bam right controllers right
exactly yeah
[Music]
yeah go ahead oh yeah this is true nice
talk hi drunk hey um so I have a quick
question um driven to to the current
slide here um the structure linear Maps
so here
um
you have a a general uh neural network
which could be a non-linear map right
and then you can enforce the eigenvalues
property on that or
or is it only applicable to certain
um kind of linear mapping function here
I I kind of have a hard time to
understand this this yes so this uh
GitHub repository slim structure linear
maps are dropping replacement for linear
weights in in pi touch that will allow
you to bound those singular values in
certain
uh upper and lower bounds
but there are some papers that
will allow you to say something about
the eigenvalue distribution of the whole
neural network when you see what type of
activation functions you're using uh we
can I can send you offline some of the
papers that are dealing with that
okay so that would be great yeah because
yeah this is basically composition of
layers and then if your upper and lower
bound of the eigenvalues of each of
those layers irregardless if it is
linear and nonlinear then you can say
something about upper and lower bound of
uh
of the overall neural network okay I see
yeah so so the current slim um two box
here it can be applied to kind of the
linear transformation right uh in neural
network uh okay but it's not like the
entire network from the input to the
output right the the layer the the
linear layer there okay exactly okay
replacement for linear layers but you
can use it as in composition to bound
the eigenvaluation of the whole neural
network I see I see all right thank you
so much thank you
very interesting okay any other
questions
oh well sounds good
um if not let's thank our speaker today
uh Jan for asking questions all right
okay okay so this is thanks for very
nice presentation so I was running when
you uh establish your uh like control
oriented model I saw you have a forward
propagating and a backward propagating
can you explain a little bit more on
that
I remember it's when you talk about the
two like the the two optimization
framework yeah this one yes
well the idea of forward and backward
path is like uh the standard in any
differentiable framework like you have
neural network layers
linear or I find transformation for by
non-linearity like classical deeper on
it and then you back propagate the
scalar value loss function through this
composite function yeah
because all of them are differentiable
and you apply the chain rule here the
idea is okay let's replace these black
box layers with something more
structured and
previously I was talking about how to
reform like constant optimization
problem in this structured computation
graph that you can compute the
sensitivities and this is the idea of
expanding that to Optimal control
problems where you have control policy
let's be neural network and your System
Dynamics model it can be neural OD or
differential equation
and then you have some layer afterwards
that represents your objective function
so instead of like having me squarator
of like being a regression function now
it's a model pretty control type
function there is like a huge family of
control theory type functionals that you
can place here as a domain priors
does it answer your question
yes cool thank you thank you very much
wonderful is is there any other
questions I mean we can take more
questions
um I'll keep going sure I have a
question
um and this was a great presentation
thank you for compiling so many great
resources along the way too
um your future Direction you you
mentioned the uncertainty quantification
pieces and I want to ask what your team
has been thinking about with the broader
questions of of trusting these types of
systems around maybe even verification
and validation and the full
um trust credibility pipeline that goes
into why a decision maker would leverage
these these approaches yeah excellent
questions uh thank you very much Aaron
so
there is like a lot of work being done
outside of our team and I would like to
also acknowledge that like uh maybe in
this slide
um these differentiable optimization
layers is one way to do so like this
differentiable convex optimization you
are embedding your optimization solver
as a layer in neural network that has
some constant satisfaction guarantees
and another one is this like DC3
learning method with higher constraints
when you leverage projections
uh some people call these methods deep
declarative networks or end-to-end
constraint optimization uh there is a
whole landscape uh projections is one
approach uh then similar idea is what we
have been exploring through these
barrier functions then you have some
surrogate model
that is providing you with the
the fitness of not like the aggregate
function but of some safety
part of the problem like the constant
satisfaction so if you are inside the
interior of constraints you have
indicator function that you are safe but
as you are approaching the boundary your
you are triggering some condition that
can trigger corrective action
so there are a lot of technical
directions that could be
applied here and I just don't know the
answer what is the solution
it is the most typically depends on the
the requirements of the application
yeah absolutely
um but that's that's very helpful to
help point back directly to where some
of those aspects are are documented
thank you I appreciate it and I see
methods like uh spawning in literature
like day by day it's a very active area
of research right if you know something
that I forgot please send me email I
would really love to hear more ideas
okay great thank you thank you
wonderful all right um
I guess one more chance
if there's any other questions please
don't be shy on mute yourself and ask
questions
well um
I guess there's no more questions
all right uh let's in that case let's
thank our speaker
um Ian they're gonna uh from cnnl uh for
giving us a wonderful talk uh what's
wrong with me uh thank you so much Jan
uh it was really wonderful presentations
I'm I'm sure
um there will be
um um you know a lot of people who would
be very interested in collaborating with
you uh including me so um expect that to
getting a lot of emails from this books
and with that let's uh you know end this
seminar series seminar today and our
ddps seminar next one is I'm not sure
this is the next week or two weeks from
now until then um
please stay healthy all right thank you
everyone
thank you very much everyone thank you